well it's hard to say uh
you know obviously they will do something that surprising
that that
current generation wouldn't expect
and even to that energy feild there's a lot of
approaches
that arent much discuss solar chemical high
winds
you know wild ideas that atleast
we need thousands of people pursuing
uh
and nine hundred ninety of them will hit dead
ends
but if that's become an urgent question
and some making sure that there's basic R&D
money that there is
uh  money to do pilots on a variety of things
I do think
uh whoever makes the breakthrough for
very cheap energy that's environmentally friendly
our multiple breakthroughs will be required
for that
they will make a huge contribution but who
knows what
what particular technology this is %uh
a case where we need to have
thousands of ideas
that are pursued